let's jump in I got a whole bunch of fun
questions and even Jason enjoyed these
let's see what you got that's great
who ruined the most cakes Hobbs our show
Wow that's a hard one probably me I'll
just take it I'll just take it it was me
I called cut too soon that was it I'll
just take the punch more likely to get
it on the first take Hobbs the show
they're obviously on abhi and I'll be
really honest on this they're different
you know they're not unlike their
characters they have different styles
Dewayne loves to come in play around
warm up Jason's comes in and he's got a
vision for it so probably Jason in that
respect yeah would be a better wingman
clubs are Shaw Wow it depends what
you're going into if you're going into
an alley fistfight you might wanna well
you could bring both I guess or if
you're going into a jovial conversation
you could also bring both I don't know
they're both they're both great wingman
it was faster at leaving their trailer
Hobbs our show ah they're both pretty
good at getting there okay
yeah that's a very diplomatic answer ah
now that they're clean shaven it's
really hard to tell we should make them
let them grow it out for a couple months
and have a contest there's pretty sorry
no no it's fine we got a total line who
wins in a fight Hobbs in Shaw or Jason
Bourne Oh Hobbs a jock come on
Hobbs in Shaw or Deadpool mcdead pool
can't be killed
but I'm not sure that Hobbs can be
either I've seen the movie so that's
probably a tough one as well
clubs in Shaw or John wick Wow
again I think it's it might be still
made in the sense
yeah neither neither group goes down the
other group goes down we just stood
there all sort of sort of invincible in
a way helps in shower John McClane
Hobson Shaw yeah yeah
John yeah you know you think you know
I'm just wondering or the terminator
Hobson shot hubs and shot or rocky with
the rocky theme music playing I think
they might even give in to rocky at that
point okay yeah
hubs in Shaw or Thanos Hobson shop okay
of the shop or the predator Hobson chop
okay it's easy
Hobson Shaw or Chev Chelios from crank
Wow
I'm still gonna say Hobson Sean that was
the first one that Statham said it could
be Jeff jealous pubs in Shaw or Bruce
Lee ooh yeah I'm a huge Bruce Lee fan so
but I would say Hobson Shaw really yeah
you're not even giving well it's two one
two on one it's two on one Hobson Shaw
or Indiana Jones does he get his whip
yes and he gets his luck yes Hobson shot
of the shot or Wolverine Hobson shot
come on okay this is a tough one yeah
Hobbs and Shaw or Ripley and aliens wow
that is a tough one that's a tough one
haha I'm just about done we're on promo
tour for Hobson Shaw my last one clubs
in Shaw or Sarah Connor in Terminator 2
it's almost the same as Ripley so I got
to give it to Hobson shot I mean they
were already beating a terminator you
know I hear what you're saying I'm gonna
respectfully say some of the others
might have beaten them but it would have
been close its close you know depends
what movie were in if we're in the
Hobson shot movie I understand maybe
we're in the Ripley movie then I might
be a toss-up god I have a million other
questions maybe I'll hit you in Hawaii
would love it
good to see them yeah really good to see